so I want to thank
I am more of a technical speaker but I
actually do have a law degree and I
noticed the person after in this room
muscle has a lot of degrees so this is
definitely a thing you know attorney
turned data scientist or software
engineer but you never really leave
being an attorney you always have those
concerns and are looking to argue so
this is something I am very interested
in and it's certainly becoming more and
more timely especially in the EU I think
you all might even know more about this
than I do because of course working in
the u.s. I continue to work in an area
that doesn't have any sort of impending
legislation regarding what I do I want
to back out I know people have sort of
different levels of awareness lots of
people just don't read the newspaper and
that's fine and this section in
particular is probably mostly for those
folks who maybe haven't been paying
attention to what's going on and the
fact that people who don't code are
starting to pay attention to what we do
I want to go all the way back to 2013
when a woman named Latanya Sweeney who
happens to have a PhD but I don't think
she put that into the Google search just
googled her name I think she was you
know thinking about looking for jobs and
thought well I want to know what my
online profile looks like my future
employers could be googling me what do I
look like and what does she see if she
sees Google as instant checkmate and the
top ad from Google Latanya Sweeney
arrested not Latanya Sweeney comma PhD
Latanya Sweeney comma arrested for those
I don't know what the UK context is
certainly in the US when I look at a
name like Latanya I'm fairly sure that's
an african-american right so I think
Latanya fairly saying hmm I wonder I
wonder if it's something to do with that
I hope not but maybe it is right so you
know she wasn't happy about this and so
she came up with some names that in the
US are more typically associated with
Caucasians like Kristen Sparrow so if
you google for Kristen Sparrow
we're just looking to contact Christian
Sparrow we're not checking or Kristen
Sparrow has been arrested interestingly
if you go to this website that was
trying to run these ads Christian
Sparrow on the bottom actually does have
a public criminal record
Latanya Sweeney doesn't and yet who is
getting the ad coming up on their name
asking if this person has been arrested
the person with the name that is
primarily an african-american name so
imagine if you are Latanya Sweeney PhD
and you find out that Google regards you
as Latanya Sweeney comma arrested it's a
little bit upsetting she went on to
write a paper about this discrimination
and online ad delivery and I think this
was really a touchstone moment and a lot
of fields of people saying hey this
seems to have gotten out of hand there
could be some really unpleasant
consequences for people in a very sort
of biased way lot's war has been going
on all right so we know that
discriminatory pricing has always been a
thing but now there are good reasons to
think it's more algorithmically driven
right rather than individual sales
people or companies being discriminatory
it's probably algorithms maybe that some
of us are writing that might be doing
this often unintentionally right so
people have been looking into how our
prices determined on the Internet in
particular right so if you look into it
you find out things like in the u.s.
Asian Americans tend to be charged more
money when they're looking into cram
schools right so again it's like let's
take a particular minority and do
something to them that we're not doing
to the majority I am NOT saying this is
being done on purpose but when you look
at what's happening to them empirically
this is what they're experiencing more
concerning still was a 2016 Pro Publica
report on a system called compass don't
know if you folks have heard of this
again mostly American context here this
is a system that is used to sort of rate
people who have been found guilty of
crimes as far as how likely they are to
commit other crimes and it's most I
suppose supposed to predict violent
crime so in 2014 as early as 2014 then
US secretary our US Attorney General
Eric
there knew about this and he warns that
these risk scores were probably racially
discriminatory there were lots of
reasons to be concerned given the
underlying data right if you take data
from a discriminatory system and often
when you look into the u.s. criminal
justice system you do find reasons to
worry that it is racially discriminatory
if you are treating your models on that
there is good reason even an attorney
who doesn't really have a technical
background pointed out there is good
reason to be concerned that you're gonna
end up with discriminatory results and
actually he asked the scent of the US
Sentencing Commission to look into this
but they decided not to it just wasn't a
priority I wasn't privy to these
decisions I'm just telling you from the
outside what we know happened so
ProPublica looked into it and they found
the scores to be pretty crappy it was
not a very good model it was probably
not even a good enough model to roll out
in production on gap calm or tesco calm
I don't know these accuracy rates were
really not so hot and the most
concerning bit was that the errors
tended to fall harshly on African
Americans and lightly on Caucasians so
African Americans when they were
misclassified were misclassified to be
violent criminals or likely to be
violent criminals labeled criminals turn
out to be wrong on the other hand when
the algorithm went wrong on what it was
to be too gentle and say this person is
fine and then they would go on to commit
crimes so the heads are the same error
rate but the error went in different
directions what other sorts of things
have been happening well apparently the
jus or not you app I mean maybe I'm an
American and I'm really uptight this
made it onto the French Apple Store way
back in 2011 this was designed by humans
so you say okay well those are racist
humans one does I have to do with
algorithmic
stuff well then we sort of moved into
stuff that was sort of more algorithmic
so Microsoft came out with a pattern
asking to help people navigate around
dangerous neighborhoods and again in the
u.s. context everybody said well when
you say dangerous neighborhoods do you
really mean you're navigating around
maybe a second American neighborhoods is
that is that sort of the easier way to
do this problem and so then you can sort
of get into a human bias and the
datasets moving into how you're training
your other them even though you probably
don't intend it even though none of
those words are in the patent
description I'm sure none of the
researchers meant it that way but they
weren't thinking about the sociology
fast forward to July 2016 and you want
to remember Pokemon go people started
noticing there aren't any of those I
don't even know what they're called the
little things you're supposed to slay
they somehow don't show up in
neighborhoods of color you have to go to
white neighborhoods to play this game
even though I assume those things were
sort of placed algorithmically somehow
it sort of stays away from the
neighborhoods of color so that we have
sort of more unintentional algorithmic
discrimination rather than the human
discrimination we started with but then
in November 2017 we come back to human
driven discrimination this is a dating
app that was released for the app store
in Singapore facially they're just
saying we help you connect with
high-quality people but apparently on
Facebook they were using racially coded
language like no maids no bangers
unpleasant stuff and you think all of
these apps past the Apple human
interface guidelines which say we need
safety we can't have objectionable
content but apparently all these these
are fine so this is just to point out
that looking at industry regulating
itself sometimes you have results that I
think at least in 2018 a lot of us say
mmmm this just gives me pause more going
on though right biased algorithms are
everywhere and no one seems to care that
seems to be the the latest headlines and
in particular I have a quote from
somebody who runs like a machine
learning auditing and fairness
consultancy who's a really famous person
who wrote a best-selling book about the
subject Cathy O'Neil if you've heard of
her she says she has no business so even
though this is getting really popular in
the new
nonetheless nobody's calling up Kathy
O'Neil to say how could we avoid being
discriminatory even though every time
people look into models they tend to
again unintentionally not on purpose
have some kind of discriminatory impact
on some kind of minority or vulnerable
population what else has been going on
the White House has issued two reports
on big data nai the first one was in
2015 the second one is it was December
2016 needless to say those were
President Obama we haven't actually seen
subsequent work from the Trump
administration but people were concerned
about this in the last administration it
is finally beginning to be something
businesses are thinking about this is
probably parently related to that I
think you know this election is more
discriminatory things coming to the
surface people are finally becoming
aware that these impact their lives so
McKenzie put out a report talking about
the business reasons to avoid
discrimination in your modelling and
sort of the big steps you can take to
avoid it first one is refrain from
asking questions whose answers will be
invalidated by algorithmic bias right
know the limits of your model don't ask
a question that your model can't really
answer especially without answering in a
discriminatory way secondly you need to
shape your data samples in such a way
that you minimize bias right so you need
to start taking ownership for your data
you can't just say that's what the data
says right you can't go into a
discriminatory situation that's been
discriminatory in the past and just say
well since that's how it was it's not
it's not really my thing and thirdly
they also say that executives have
probably not us more people who aren't
coding so much should also know when to
use and not to use machine learning
algorithms now the way I see it the
people in this room most of us anyway
are largely responsible for this first
two but we also have to remember that
we're all usually at some level up
answering to someone who doesn't code
right and so we also need to be able to
explain the limitations which means we
need to take some ownership more things
have been going on well this is just an
unreadable slide I just typed in
artificial intelligence New York Times
so presumably these are some of their
most read or most links to articles
Reese
and if you can't weight it too well but
I would say that 80% of them are about
algorithmic bias it's just sort of that
easy to spot reporters can pick it up so
people are getting interested in
regulating this in the US I think we are
definitely behind sort of timeline was
the EU we are sort of on the national
level just looking to define AI and
define what algorithmic intelligence or
automation should be just a legal
definition so we have funded a task
force to do that and that was sort of
late last year that's as far as we've
gotten in the US what we are seeing
though is there are local legislative
efforts so for example my hometown New
York City it's just a city but we're
also one of the biggest cities we've got
8 million people just within the city
limits very liberal sort of activist
jurisdictions so actually a New York
City Councilman in December of 2017 got
interested in this and he says all of
these city services are being allocated
algorithmically the city is paying
vendors to sell us products to tell us
how to make decisions but at the same
time they don't give us the source code
and they don't really tell us even what
data sets they trained on I'm a little
concerned about this and especially he
is a person of color from the Bronx so
of course he's saying I in particular
and worried that my constituents who are
mostly for minority communities are in
some way being treated worse than they
otherwise would be with these algorithms
so I would like to see some code
he got some pushback and what ended up
happening is instead of the legislation
he wanted which was to just see the code
I want to see it you have to disclose it
if it's used in city services we have
again a task force to sort of look into
what we can do and of course there is
going to be pushback from industry not
wanting to share proprietary data
sources or proprietary code which is of
course totally legitimate so we are
still and in the u.s. seeking a balance
or figuring out where we would even
begin to start addressing this problem
on the other hand in the EU you guys
know all about this and my Under
this is about to really become a thing
and you are about to have a presentation
right after this one about how that is
going to affect you so I'm actually
curious if by a show of hands people
could say is this something that you are
talking about it work is this something
that's modifying your workflow raise
your hand if yes and raise your hand if
no okay so very few are not affected now
when I ask this question in US
presentations where there isn't some
legal rule coming into force creating
liability and creating the option to
have some insight into what is going on
for the average person nobody raises
their hand there are not really ethics
discussions there are not regulatory
discussions there is not auditing that
has been my experience with audiences
and in my work experience so I don't
know what the general mood in this room
is about this legislation I did find
this Center for data innovation report
about this eg legislation coming out and
I noticed some of the reasons they were
fighting regulation which sound very
familiar to the reasons I hear in the US
for example requiring companies to
manually review significant algorithmic
decisions raises the overall cost of AI
and the right to explanation could
reduce AI accuracy the right to erasure
could damage a I systems the prohibition
on repurposing data will restrain AI
innovation these might all be true but
what I see here that concerns me
especially as an attorney is I don't see
any sort of risk benefit and that is
what has that is what is often missing
from an unregulated industry and that is
what has been missing in our industry to
some extent you don't have to balance
you don't need to say well my algorithm
will be less accurate or more costly to
develop but will it be fair or will it
ruin a few where people's lives are
ruined fewer people's days even and so I
think what is going to happen is we're
going to see a shift in all of our
industries we're working in we're
instead of just saying what would be
really cool or what would be amazing or
how do we get that data set people will
hopefully begin to say well yeah but
there's also a cost and we need to
incorporate that right rather than
everything being an externality we're
going to see that these costs get
integrated in not necessarily a bad
thing and I would point out that a lot
of these complaints that people have
sound very similar to other industry is
sort of R&D type industries and they're
all thriving for example Pharma right or
aviation when they first started to be
regulated they said you know you're
going to kill us and actually everyone's
doing great so keep that in mind more
nefarious bloopers few of us know about
right not everything makes it into the
news not at all so I can share a
personal story for example I read a
crunchbase story about a company that
had started predicting loan defaults and
I think it was her student loans in
particular and they profiled sort of the
genius young people who were doing this
and good for them I other bear no ill
well but they said oh we figured out
this really cool thing people who have
to change their phone numbers often
default on their loans and we think
there is just something kind of
irresponsible about people who change
their phone numbers and I had just
changed my phone number and and so I was
really upset and I was even more upset
because I had changed my phone number
because I was being harassed by somebody
and so this made me think oh I was a
vulnerable person being harassed and
that would actually impact my credit
score even though I've always paid my
bills on time so I think if you all sort
of read the news you'll probably all
find something that applies to you and
then it begins to feel a little more
personal and of course there are the
things we don't even know about
okay so we all want to be fair right so
why do we even have to have this
discussion well I think we all have
general rules that we all think we agree
about right like treat everyone equally
oh that seems like the default unless we
have some reason not to and then I run
into things like this on reddit like you
can very easily find out that Target
which is this big store in America takes
the same shoelaces for women and for men
literally the same SKU and they put an
extra sticker on the woman's just so
they can charge them more so it's
literally the same packaging it arrives
at the store they put the extra sticker
on the women and they put it in a
different section and you will only find
this out if you go to the men's section
and the women's section and
I thought I feel like someone did like a
like a deaf female markup and like their
boss was just like try to maximize your
profit and we have figured out that
women will pay more than men so let's
let them pay more than that right and I
I don't know I don't really know what
the answer is right is it good that if
people are willing to pay more they
should pay more or if they've been
trained to pay more they should pay more
well maybe and maybe not but this this I
am 99% convinced came out of somebody
writing a function to figure out exactly
what the markup should be and look at
the data right so think about how this
is getting into people's work lives
fairly quickly also if you are gonna
discriminate you usually want to do it
for a reason right like for example we
treat children differently from adults
but we actually have a reason right they
might kill themselves if we leave them
unsupervised on the other hand we don't
tend to sort of give different adults
different rules right we say we're all
competent often what will happen with
unintentional discrimination if you have
things where people make a requirement
that's not really necessary but it
somehow impacts one group of people more
than another a very common example in
the u.s. was requiring a high school
diploma for jobs that really did not
require a high school diploma and
effectively what was happening is the
high school diploma was being used as a
proxy for race especially in the south
of the u.s. sort of pre civil rights era
when it was very difficult for a person
of color to get a high school diploma
and so there was a very famous US
Supreme Court case they found this Power
Company you could start any job without
a high school diploma but you couldn't
sort of transfer or advance without a
high school diploma even though the jobs
you were trying to advance to also had
nothing to do with a high school diploma
and it was most nefarious about this is
these requirements have been put in just
as the civil rights era was beginning
you know as people of color we're
beginning to question the limitations in
their lives and beginning to say hey why
don't I ask for promotion why don't I
ask for a transfer this company said oh
so sorry you don't have a high school
diploma we'd love to help you but right
so there are things like this or for
example the one I just cited right phone
number change as a proxy for being
harassed right maybe the reason that
it's a
predictor of who's gonna default is that
those people are having trouble in their
lives that has nothing to do with their
ability to pay or willingness to pay but
it's sort of an easy way to just
discriminate in some way right you have
to make a decision why not use this easy
variable that you have in your data set
also I think we usually all agree we
don't want to kick people in there down
right that feels unsporting and yet
people without job experience usually
can't get a job can't get the experience
and especially when I see I haven't
worked I'd like an AI recruiting company
there are tons of them it's an important
problem but I often worry that people
who are developing algorithms at these
companies are doing the same thing are
reproducing this difficult job market
where people who are down who don't have
the experience can't even get past the
algorithm that is selecting the resumes
and that's something to think about
right
similarly former criminals also write
the guy out of jail lots of them really
do want to restart their lives don't
want to get involved in crime again and
yet they run into the same problem oh
you've got a criminal history right like
our algorithm you're you're done like we
can move you forward
sorry and so people aren't running into
these algorithmic walls they used to run
into human walls we are basically
reproducing those walls or maybe even
making them less porous right so maybe
you used to be a criminal and you would
go in and you would say I know it's
really bad but please please give me a
chance now you can't even beg an
algorithm right it's not a person
anymore who might maybe have some gifts
so that's something to think about
finally why does this require research
and training right this is actually a
very complicated area it is an area of
active research a couple of things one
is that often the datasets themselves
are uninterpretable I grabbed this from
some kind of ecology paper so it has
nothing to do with anything sociology
but I have often worked on human data
sets they kind of look like this right
and at least when I initially look at
them I'm like what conclusion can I draw
nothing or I plot things out it can be
very difficult to look at a model look
at your visualizations and know that
you're discriminating but there might be
something in there similarly most data
scientists and analysts
have a quantitative educational
background and possibly got trapped
there very early especially you guys in
the EU my understanding is once you get
to university level you're just kuang
kuang kuang kuang kuang at least in the
u.s. we sort of like you know you do a
little quant maybe one English class on
the side but I get the impression it's a
very tracked educational system and what
that means is many of us have a limited
sociological sociological educational
background right we haven't done a whole
lot of reading about social problems
right that's another degree course we
don't have time for that totally valid
that means that we might not be aware of
the complexities of the models that are
the situations we're trying to model and
for all these reasons it can be
difficult to spot when you are
unintentionally discriminating
especially in Y datasets this is an
example I'm going to come back to later
but I think we can look at this and say
there's like 17 white guys and three
white women this might have you know
been the outcome of something that was
somewhat discriminatory just depending
on where we were drawing from okay so
how are we going to decide what actually
is discriminatory right we can debate
this forever we can have like little
three end discussions what's really
interesting for researchers is to just
let the law drive the decision right the
law has already made a decision about
what discrimination is let's go out and
find that right that's where society has
come to some kind of conclusion about
what things should be happening and what
things shouldn't be happening and that's
already difficult to find difficult to
prove oh there's two definitions and
these are active in the EU and in the US
this is sort of the same lingo versus
disparate treatment right this is the
really bad one this is like when you
sort of intend to discriminate you don't
see this too often but it is out there
and obviously shouldn't happen what's
much more common as what's called
disparate impact you basically give
unfair treatment via unjustified factors
that end up making a protected class
receive worse treatment so for example
that Apple the example I gave with the
high school diploma right jobs I have
nothing to do with high school diploma
you nonetheless put that hurdle there it
tended to be at the time that all the
whites got past it and none of the
friggin Americans so when you look at
that that's this for an impact another
word for this is called redlining this
comes from US banks used to just pick
and tire zip codes and give nobody a
mortgage in those zip codes and
interestingly when you looked at those
zip codes on one side of this graphic
are the zip codes of people who couldn't
get mortgages for their houses and the
other side is African American zip codes
and what do we notice these are
identical maps right so this is another
example of how you can in this case I
think this was probably intentional
discrimination but if you are putting
zip code into your model quite
innocently you might effectively be
doing something very similar to this
without having any intention of doing so
so those two definitions very much match
for example two of the App Store apps I
talked about on the Left we've got
disparate treatment
remember no maids no bangle is right so
an intentionally discriminatory app
explicitly so and on the right we've got
disparate impact right where I am
assuming pokemons go did not intend
not-so-big make this game playable
equally by people of all colors but that
is what happened a couple of other sort
of terms that people talk about genuine
occupational requirement this is are you
actually requiring something to be hired
that is necessary and if again if you're
working for example for a recruiting AI
firm something like that this is
something that will affect you you
should be aware that genuine
occupational requirements change over
time racist sanity changes our idea of
what's necessary to do a job also
changes and I say that only remind you
that when you are putting requirements
in your algorithms ask yourself whether
they are really necessary or that's just
something you are used to and you've
always done and a good example of this
is the Armed Forces in the u.s. the
Armed Forces in the u.s. were segregated
even as late as World War two somehow
people said oh if we combine everybody
they're going to be race riots like we
can't do it we just we can't work that
way so one sort of occupational
requirement was you had to be in a unit
of the same race then up until 2015
women were like technically not able to
come
you know they could not be in combat
roles and even as they said that lots of
American women were out in villages in
Afghanistan or Iraq doing combat work
but not getting combat pay that's how
actually what ended up happening because
they needed women to talk to the women
there so they had a go but if they were
killed they were killed not an option
and that has significant repercussions
for your family
and for what kind of pension your family
will receive similarly the transgender
ban in the US military was justified as
oh we can't really operate this way it
just can't work and that ended up
getting lifted too so over the last
century we have seen sort of our idea
about what is required change how does
this apply to our field well you know
one of these things is the success of
the wizkid entrepreneur right there's
this idea that you have to be young that
maybe you have to be a certain gender or
a certain race to do tech when people
look into this empirically it's not
actually true and so this is an example
when you wonder how people are deciding
who gets funding or even how algorithms
are deciding what startups are promising
are they even looking at the right
factors another set of language that is
helpful the group under-representation
principle so I showed you this picture
before this picture on the left is the
board of the New York City Subway what
is the New York City Subway look like
when you actually take it it looks more
like this this is what I see when I get
on the subway actually a lot more
crowded but it's very diverse
it's very ethnically diverse um so I was
fairly shocked when I saw this picture
this is this is not an algorithmic leave
selected group of people but this is a
group of people that were sort of
selected from different sources so every
way every organization gets to pick one
person they don't get together and just
tend to discriminate but they all you
know sort of put people into a pool and
this is what happens so for example if
you have some sort of algorithm that's
maybe sharing with other algorithms and
other groups you might have something
like this happen and in fact this is
sort of what happened at Facebook as
well right and not super diverse group
of people burden of proof and situation
testing um so how do you look for
discrimination traditionally the law
likes to really prove discrimination
we'd like to prove you started with one
person and another and the only
difference between them was something
that's not supposed to matter right they
have identical resumes except one as a
person of color and what one is not or
one as a woman and one is not or one is
heterosexual and one is not and you want
to be able to prove as tightly as you
can that this truly was intentional
discrimination or unintentional but
nonetheless discrimination so here's an
example actually from Donald Trump's
housing project that he owned in Queens
where the Department of Justice this was
back in the 70s or 80s sent people in
people who are white and people who were
not white sort of similar income similar
references from their landlords somehow
all the people who were not white there
just weren't any apartments available so
this is an example of situation testing
how does this apply in our world well
interestingly in the u.s. right now it
is technically illegal to look for
discrimination in online algorithms so
you are a researcher you want to find
out if you know fill in your favorite
web site is discriminating I think
people do this website but technically
on the books we have the Computer Fraud
and Abuse Act which says that if you
provide false information to a website
which you would have to do to provide
Zook discrimination research that is
actually a criminal offense the second
offense right so if you do it once and
then you do it a second time the second
offense is punishable by up to 10 years
in prison so right now there's ongoing
litigation with researchers saying we
can't even look for discrimination
because it is technically a crime and
well no one has gone to jail for this
the fact that you could is awfully scary
so a couple of concepts there that are
pretty interesting obviously this has
been noticed by the legal community
there are lots of different ways to sort
of look for discrimination a very
popular one is the Reuben causal model
where you try to look at the individual
level if I take one individual and the
only thing I tweaked about them is the
protective thing that's not supposed to
matter and my outcome changes I have a
problem that's sort of the simplest
version this is the easiest way you can
already audit your own work right if you
are doing a model
and you just change the gender or the
race of the individual you are modeling
and your outcome changes drastically you
should be concerned so I don't think we
have much more time yeah so we started
late I'm going to skip this section and
just go straight to some specific things
about your workflow so data discovery
you want to be aware that biased
sampling and sampling context are really
prevalent especially in areas where
people are doing high-stakes modeling
criminal datasets for example are often
collected as a result of police action
if your enforcement is biased of course
your sampling is going to be biased
where some that if the enforcement is
not just biased in terms of the rate but
creates different stressors for example
the police rough up a certain gender or
a certain race more than they rough up
other genders or races the way people
react is also going to be different if
you're predicting low incidence events
and many of us do because these are the
things that are really catastrophic or
really profitable or whatever we're
generally working with really meager
data sets so we usually use
supplementary data what happens there
well for example that system compass
that I told you about that tends to
mislabel black people as guilty and
white people as not guilty as it were
was built to predict sort of violent
crimes like murder that are low
incidents how do they do it they
supplemented their data with lots of non
violent crime and so they use that
supplementary data from non violent
crime coming from possibly biased police
enforcement and that might explain part
of why they have such sort of racially
inflected errors so you want to ask are
your supplementary data when you need to
use them introducing an unjustified bias
into the actual event you want to
predict you also want to think about
under weighting or over weighting
protected groups many machine learning
algorithms are going to favor your
majority behavior you want to be aware
of that because minority groups might
not behave the same way your function is
not necessarily monotonic across all
your bins so individuals might be
penalized just because you don't have
enough data sets like that here's an
example in US polling analysis
anyone who's not white that's just our
category like you can be an
african-american male and that's her
misty tell us you get where his whites
get broken down into like white forty to
fifty educated suburban woman just
because there's more things about those
people but what that ends up meaning is
certain individuals get much more sort
of tailored accurate treatment than
others
just because of their race what can you
do about this right you can be aware but
what if you've only got bias it's data
data massaging you can effectively real
able to make your world better how do
you do this you literally change the
labels when you can identify for example
people in the protected group who were
most egregiously discriminated against
you can actually flip the labels on some
of them and give them the more favorable
outcome for example that they ought to
have had or take away the favorable
label from some of the favorite group
that shouldn't have had that label so
you can do that you can relate your data
so you can say okay I'm gonna find in
the deprived group the people who were
discriminated against I'm gonna weigh
them more and try to sort of underweight
the people who were discriminated
against because I don't want my model to
redo that same behavior you can also do
corrective sampling same idea one
important idea is to know that the
tension between fairness and accuracy is
not nearly as great as it sometimes in
charge right so sometimes people say oh
you can be fair but your model is gonna
be terrible that's actually not true
there's a lot of research in this so all
these things on the left are different
sort of fairness algorithms people are
trying to develop what you will notice
is you can cut your discrimination and
there's lots of ways to measure this by
a factor of eight right from 16% to 2%
while only cutting your average accuracy
from 86% to basically 84% so imagine if
you're making a decision like who goes
to jail for a long time and who gets to
go home and take care of their family
and you can get rid of all your
discrimination and maybe only let one
extra criminal girlfriend and that might
be
good trade-off right so this sort of
accuracy fairness trade-off is not
really the trade-off people say it is I
will just finish my modeling section I'm
so checking your model for
discrimination really basic things
sometimes you might have assumptions in
there you don't even realize you have
them and tell us too late so for example
in 2008 when they sort of did the
postmortem they found that a lot of
banks had models after the financial
crisis or before the financial crisis
that didn't even allow for negative
changes in housing prices somebody
thought they should just have a variable
that could only go positive I mean
that's not even easy to program but
somehow people thought it was that
obvious thought it was true so think
about whether your models have built-in
constraints that suggest confirmation
bias or stability bias throwing in lots
of variables is actually dangerous right
it's something we're all and trying to
do we have more and more algorithms
actually designed for why datasets and
yet the wider your data set the more
likely you are discriminating because
many of those attributes you're throwing
in maybe just for fun like zip code turn
out to mostly be predicting race and
that's how it's sort of impacting your
outcome so you don't want to increase
your risk of redlining finally how are
you choosing your loss function are you
choosing a loss function that fairly
measures the cost of misclassification
or are you choosing a loss function that
is computationally efficient regardless
of social class right this is where the
cool background we all have rather than
a sociology background might be a
disadvantage right are you thinking
about the true cost to everybody
involved and are you treating all
misclassifications the same even though
some are more costly than others right
you don't want to assume symmetry and
are you applying the same loss function
across a variety of populations or
cultures without domain knowledge so I
will end there since we are out of time
anyone who's interested in my slides
please just shoot me an email and I will
I will send them to you there's more
concrete guidance including also some
links to really concrete guidance as to
how you can implement this at work
[Applause]
oh so there's lots of different ways
they're like policies of fairness that
you can consider which favor different
metrics or different approaches is it do
you think that you could say that
there's like one best one some best
fairness policy for all or is it for
each group and individual to define
fairness policy which is best suited to
their usage so firstly what constitutes
discrimination tends to be legally
established so if your organization's
goal is to not discriminate in the legal
sense that tends to be fairly well
defined and that's gonna be just looking
at sort of group level but of course
there are for example individual level
fairness concerns also right in my
arbitrarily punishing some individuals
maybe not even on the basis of some
protected category like race maybe just
you know my my algorithm is not as sort
of stable as I would like it to be and
that's something where your individual
organization has to decide sort of what
decision are we making what's gonna hurt
people the most
hey thanks for great salt I was just
wondering you mentioned you know that we
essentially had human decision-makers
who had by seas and other just being
movements to the algorithmic world I
just wonder are you optimistic that
algorithms can improve the situation in
future if we do properly like it like
there's a bright way exist or even if it
isn't at the moment I absolutely think a
right way exists I I am a big proponent
of transparency and having datasets and
algorithms be as open as possible where
possible because to me people people go
back and forth on this and they say well
in the past it was you know biased
racially biased judges hand a man with a
sentences and that's just as horrible as
a racially biased algorithm on the plus
side the judge had to actually write a
decision that you could challenge where
is right now compass just shoots out a
score that you can't challenge but a
judge can also sort of lie or massage
their reasons right the reason that they
say which might even be the reason they
believe might not really be the
explanatory reason with an algorithm if
you can see everything that's going on
and if it's reasonably interpretive all
which is its own problem then you can
see incorrect what's going on so I think
it is the way forward but I truly
believe only with the right regulation
because I think what we have seen is
people don't tend to disclose without
this compulsion and why should they
right it's a competitive marketplace but
if you have the right legal regime that
favors both innovation and fairness I
think you can strike a very good balance
and the last question thank you for the
talk I was wondering if I do something
wrong as a person I'm like a
discriminate so I would be punished
let's say what's about sin the
programmers who do this algorithm
who's going to be judge sitting of the
day so if I support Graham I'd do
something silly and I came up with this
algorithm so does discriminate and it
was basically my fault but no for
devotees thing about it so I think that
we actually belong to a profession that
does
have an obligation to the end users of
our programs I hope that profession like
whatever you want to call yourself data
scientist software engineer analyst
however you identify just like other
white-collar professions have a
fiduciary duty or some sort of like duty
to the people who are using their their
products I think we have that I would
like to see it formalized just like for
example doctors and attorneys have it
formalized
to say yes we have a Professional
Responsibility I think about these
people I think Europe tends to go
farther than the US for example my
understanding is that not that it's
common but airline executives can go to
jail if a plane crashes and it turns out
that they were doing shoddy work that
wouldn't happen in the US and I don't
think it really happens here that often
so I don't really want to see people
going to jail because they
unintentionally wrote discriminatory
algorithms but I would I think what
happens right now is often there's a
business bottom line and possibly your
supervisor is not that interested in
these questions because we all have a
bottom line right we need to pay for our
salaries we need to keep our
organization growing I think what
happens is when you put it into the law
and it becomes a requirement then people
talk about it if it's not a requirement
there's just somehow never time to worry
about it because there are always
business priorities so I think we want
to shift it just to get people the room
and the obligation to think about this
and audit their model rather than having
to push the model out the door as soon
as it's reasonably accurate without
knowing whether it's discriminatory so I
think we have a duty but not in the
sense that I want people punished or
something like that
[Applause]